democrat caught skirting the rules and
mandates they want everyone else to
follow
so we first saw it when speaker nancy
pelosi went to a hair salon in san
francisco despite restrictions keeping
them closed for the public you'll
remember that
and then california governor gavin
newsom was busted breaking his own coven
19 restrictions by going to a dinner
party at the french
laundry and that is an upscale
restaurant jesse can't wait to go to
and now president biden's climate czar
john kerry is being called a hypocrite
over a resurface 2019 video here he is
defending taking a private jet to accept
a climate award in iceland
if you offset your carbon it's the only
choice for somebody like me
who is traveling the world to win this
battle
i believe the time it takes me to get
somewhere i can't sail across the ocean
i have to fly
to meet with people and get things done
jesse let me start with you so at the
time of this interview in 2019
john kerry wasn't the czar of anything
he couldn't have signed
america up like what battle on is he
trying
who's he fighting for i don't get it
john kerry's fighting climate change by
changing the climate
stop fighting so hard john i mean this
guy's carbon footprint is so big
exxon mobil is going to give him an
award i just ran
his profile the guys got five homes
five suvs but he just sold his nantucket
property because they were about to put
wind turbines that were going to destroy
his view and his property value
so then he took the profits and bought a
place on the vineyard instead for 11.5
million
i saw the aerial shot dana i couldn't
see any solar panels on it
but i assume that laid off miners are
very busy building them
we know it's very dangerous to live on
the coast because of those rising
sea levels thank goodness john kerry
knows breaststroke
and he can breaststroke himself to
safety the only green
job that joe biden has created has been
for kerry
and it's not even green by the way who's
paying for the jet fuel
where he's flying all over the world are
the taxpayers paying for that and are we
also
paying for the carbon offsets what a
great scam
someone should ask saki about that and
greg
the reporter that asked him about it was
from an icelandic reporter
and he was like hey by the way you're
here to do climate but you're in this
private jet
and you know they were supposed to love
the media the media was kind of
needling them there and now it's come
back to bite them um
you sure that wasn't bjork i don't know
um
look um offsets are basically our our
generation's version of indulgences
as long as you you can afford uh offsets
you can do whatever you want
let's not forget de blasio's excuse for
using a motorcade to go to the gym
across town was that
my climate advice is enough
of a contribution that i can abuse the
advice you see it's a cancelling out
thing
can i go completely off topic for a
moment okay
i think a bigger problem than political
hypocrisy
because political hypocrisy will never
go away we will do this story forever
it's a cultural hypocrisy in which the
political hypocrisy is embedded right
how did harvey weinstein or roman
polanski or now marilyn manson
get away with all their grim assaults
even though everyone
knew it was going on it's it's
it's because culture culturally
it is easier to to take advantage
and skirt the rules as long as you
follow the liberal orthodoxy
the cultural orthodoxy of liberalism
allows you under the guise of tolerance
to get away with anything you want
so yes you can get into politics like
carrie and you can
override the laws that you set but if
you get into culture
if you become a rock star or a tv star a
celebrity
you can get away with stuff that's so
disgusting
you cannot even say it on tv and we will
not say it here but we will imagine it
indeed you will you're a sick person i
am thinking about that
um you know getting mono from the ken
doll still like affected me from
yesterday no i'm sorry
hey juan so this week it was reported
that all these countries that signed
onto the paris climate accord are not
going to meet
their stated goals of reducing emissions
why was it so important for the binding
administration to re-sign up
if none of the other countries are going
to make their goals
well i think the idea is that we could
set an example and we could
inspect but we already insist that they
do meet their goals but we already met
ourselves well i think that's the i well
we weren't in it
we weren't it we're meeting our we're
trying to meet our goals
they need to meet their goals i mean
that's that's what the deal is and i
think we have an important role to play
there
as global leaders i think that's what
the united states should be
by the way on john kerry i don't think
there's much way to defend now obviously
this happened in 2019
and to jesse's question obviously he was
paying for that fuel
uh not the united states government not
the taxpayer and by the way john kerry's
wife
is richer than john kerry right so i
mean john kerry's wife is rich beyonce
that's teresa hines
but it's bad optics for anybody who's
the climate czar and he's going to have
to learn about public relations for a
climate
czar because he's got to be able to set
an example now having said all that
i think it's not good for us to nitpick
uh what greg called earlier you know
sort of political hypocrisy because
there's
that's just so rampant it is important
for us to look beyond
all the hypo hypocrites the who was it
there was some guy down in austin who
went to a wedding there was the
you know governor of california and
really look at climate change
the policies the important things about
dealing with climate change remains
important to all of us
and we need to deal with it and we
should not get derail by
nitpicking political hypocrisy all right
but
degan we do it so well i actually don't
i
i don't i john kerry should i wish he
spoke with like a french or some sort of
amorphous european accent
because that way at least it would kind
of be a better indicator of his ego and
his arrogance and how much he loves
himself did you notice how many times he
he said i i am i can't take a ship
across the sea
well i don't i'm not that concerned with
how he's traveling i'm
worried about what he's doing on these
travels screwing over americans to suck
up to nations that well hate us who want
to [ __ ] our economy
with higher energy prices fewer jobs and
make us once again dependent
on foreign oil communist china you think
you think they're going to meet their
promises
no they don't give a damn about the
climate by the way our emissions per
capita the lowest they've been
since 1950 because of natural gas but
kerry's climate end game is to just
drive up the cost of you commuting to
work assuming that you have a job left
after four years dramatically more
greenhouse gas emissions
from that pipeline being canceled
because of how they will have to
get that natural gas to and from all
right
great talk every